well the $200 price point for graphics
cards is definitely heating up and with
that X like the comment section to
probably also heat up with this video so
I'm gonna go ahead and put on some eye
protection
get the amazing sound to playing our
magnetic headphones with the X - H e4 x
axis from drop highly efficient magnetic
planar design and adjustable fit make
them the perfect pair for anyone seeking
legendary audio without the legendary
price tag to learn more and to take
advantage of the current sale of the - 4
X X's head to the drop in the link below
alright so obviously AMD has just
launched its 5,500 xt 4 gig and 8 gig
cards the only difference between those
2 cards is the amount of VRAM on there
which is very much so how they used to
do it with the Polaris series with the
484 75 85 70 they'd have a four gig an 8
gig variant where other than that the
core is the same so what we did here is
we also used a couple of different
Nvidia cards here because we like to
show how the competition stacks up
versus the price points so we did was we
took a 16 16 50 in a 16 50 super and a
16 60 although this is an expensive 16
60 well caveat that one in a second
we'll talk about why to sort of see how
the performance is right around that
$200 entry point when it comes to the
very competitive $200 entry point for
graphics cards because that is according
to these steam statistics where most
people tend to spend their money in
terms of graphics cards 50th 60 series
cards at 1080p resolution 1080p is still
be overwhelming dominant resolution so
looking at these cards at this price
point for 1080p makes perfect sense now
let's go and talk about what is new with
AMD first of all this is on their seven
nanometer architecture so it is PCIe 4.0
although this card is nowhere near fast
enough to come anywhere close to
saturating even PCIe gen3 4.0 is just
quite honestly a marketing thing that's
because AMD has 4.0 on the rise on three
stuff you got to put it on the GPUs -
but I'm with this card it's not and
we're close to being 4.0 but that's a
little bit of a rant it's also launched
with new software the adrenalin 2020
series so the driver for a Radeon is a
bit different than Nvidia where NVIDIA
has GeForce experience that is a
standalone piece of software the
complement your graphics card it's not
required you don't have to download it
in fact it's an option and you can
uncheck when you download the driver the
driver otherwise is still a very basic
GUI that you can right-click on you're
just
click on Nvidia settings and get a very
slow and outdated menu to control some
3d settings for your graphics cards but
with Radeon it is baked into the driver
now I have been a huge hater of the
Radeon software global wot man it's
bugginess it's its overhead that it uses
in terms of processing power you can
actually get lower scores across the
board with it open versus it closed
which you have to have it open to get
accurate truly accurate readings of
things like junction temperature and
edge temp and the core speed and all
that sort of stuff so it's like opened
me up to see how things are running to
cause me to run slower and I've always
hated the Radeon software but it's been
completely redesigned from the ground up
with the journal in 2020 includes things
like built-in streaming software which
we're gonna do a review on because it's
gonna then do all of your stream
capturing at a driver level which sounds
like it could be very low overhead so we
want to test that sort of stuff
especially if you're trying to do live
streaming with something like 5500 XT
it's got a much more user intuitive
global wot man when it comes to tuning I
think they even just call it Tunis now I
tested it a little bit with these cards
but for the test you saw today all the
cards were run out of the box settings
no manual overclocks no additional boost
clock any of that it's just how it
performed out of the box the software is
something I want to do a full standalone
review of at least the the when it comes
to things like AMD boost or Radeon boost
letting the software kind of dynamically
adjust the resolution based on movement
so it's something we'll be taking a look
at in the future not necessarily in this
review this is a raw horsepower review
when it comes to these graphics cards
the cards we chose from Nvidia this kind
of it's kind of segues me back into the
argument that I sort of had recently
with the whole like Nvidia your products
deck is way too freakin crowded we were
even having a hard time trying to
determine where to draw the line in the
sand to cut off which graphics cards
we're going to test when it comes to
tears because every like 30 bucks when
it comes to Nvidia has a whole different
tier of graphics cards that you can shop
from you've got sixteen fifty sixteen
fifty super sixteen sixteen sixteen
sixty super 16 60 TI and all of those
are within like thirty dollars of each
other
and if you take into account the custom
board variants from the AI bees each one
of those have like three or four
different SKUs within that same tier
which can make it bump right up into the
price or exceed the price of the next
tier enter the GTX 1660 gaming X that
costs more money than the super and is
slower we use this card though to
represent the 1660 because one it's the
only one I have here right now and then
two we went back and checked all of our
our spreadsheets of all of our testing
and stuff and it was absolutely no
faster than the msi our the EVGA 1660
black which is an MSRP card it was
exactly the same so there was zero
benefit to that card over an MSRP even
though this one comes in at 249 dollars
it performs the same as the card that
was like two hundred and nine dollars so
just wanted to go ahead and point that
out there but the MSRP for the 1660
super is two hundred and twenty nine
dollars but if we look right now at
Amazon because this is actually prior to
the launch of this Amazon has already
leaked the pre-order whatever for the
1550 1550 1550 the 5500 XT the XFX rx
5500 XT thick two pro eight gig is $229
which puts you right at the MSRP for the
1660 super now we didn't even include
the super on this test even though the
pricing is the same because we wanted to
see how they 1660 which is the next
generation or next tier up from the 1650
series that we're testing against how
this performs so if this outperforms
these cards will the 5500 XT cards and
the super definitely will but it's just
one of those things where it kind of
shows that as much as I hate in videos
products that it probably made sense
anyway let's go and take a look at the
benchmarks
[Music]
so if we learned anything from these
benchmarks it's that the four gig in the
8 gig really there's no performance
difference between these two cards which
is kind of a good thing and a bad thing
and we'll talk about that in a sec I
know it's trying to balance it that's
not gonna wait there we go there whoa
there we go all of our titles are at
1080p max settings and we usually put
the settings at the top of the chart if
you're kind of wondering how far you
push these cards I always do max
settings because I like to show you what
the worst-case performance scenario is
gonna be so that you know it'll only go
up from there but with the exception of
Red Dead Redemption 2 which is a much
newer much more demanding title and
probably I don't know if it's less
optimized or what it is a console port
so there is that but what I do is I took
the 1650s super I placed it on the test
bench dialed in the presets not any of
the custom stuff that you can control in
there but just the preset slider to
where I got about 60 FPS with the 1650s
super and then locked it down there and
tested the rest of the cards with the
same settings that setting happens to be
the very first tick of balanced so it's
kind of weird the way Red Dead works
it's not like a 1 through 10 it's not
like a low medium high very high ultra
it's favored performance favorite
performance favorite performance balancé
balancé balancé balancé favor quality
favor quality favor quality it's really
weird so there's like 4 ticks of
balanced in the middle it's the very
first tick if you're wondering the one
that we chose and then obviously 1080p
no Envy no Envy League
no no be sync or any of that sort of
stuff and then what we found it was a
little bit anomalous to where even the
1660 which is obviously faster than the
rest of these cards on the table was
getting the same FPS as even like the 4
gigabyte card in the wall the 1650 super
and all that sort of stuff so I think
that could be just title optimization
I'm not entirely sure but with that said
you might be asking yourself why the
cards we chose were on the chart well it
has everything do with pricing or 160
999 is what the 4 gig 5,500 XT is MSRP
at $199.99 us is what the 8 gigas is
priced at so $30.00 Delta there between
both cards well if you take that into
account
it kind of makes the 8gig card a lot
less of a value because at least in the
test that we were running it was
absolutely no difference it was $30
towards a spec that we are not utilizing
which makes that obviously the
compelling buy versus the other 1600
series cards but if you're looking at
the eight gigabyte card
it's a weird pricing structure because
AMD chose to price these cards right up
against the 1660 super pricing well 1660
for sure but 1660 super you can have as
low as $229 no but J this is 199 that's
$30 more that that doesn't make sense
well I don't know what these cards are
gonna cost it either you guys know the
games that manufacturers play with MSRP
right usually the AIB cards cost more
that's because they put more R&D into it
you have custom PCBs custom coolers duel
fans you know back plates all that sort
of stuff so it's one of those things
where I don't know what this card is
gonna cost I don't know if the sapphire
pulse and I'm holding right here is
going to cost MSRP so once this video
goes live and then everything hits the
retailers we'll have to see what the
pricing ends up being but at the 5500 XT
8 gigabyte ends up being anywhere near
215 220 dollars let's face it they're
never 15 they're never 5 it's always 209
to 19 to 29 they love the nines right
it's a way to get next for 10 bucks
without feeling like you're spending 10
extra bucks but I digress then it
becomes a lot less of a value because
you can get better raw performance at
the 1660 series 60 60 non-super even or
even a 1650 super because it's now
definitely in the price point of a 1650
super and then depending on the titles
will depend on where you get more FPS
now it definitely trades blows with the
1650 super no problems there 16:50
handedly beats it even the four gate the
four gig versus the 1650 non-super is a
no-brainer get the 5500 but as soon as
you start taking into account custom PCB
is going up against the extremely
crowded product stack of Nvidia then it
gets to the point to where it becomes a
lot harder of a decision to make
not so much whether or not to get the
5500 XT versus the 1660 and the supers
it's more so which 1660 or 1660 super do
you buy it's never been this crowded
we've never had this many cards down at
the 200 ish dollar price point as long
as I've been doing YouTube we've had a
50 series a 60 series a 70 and an 80 and
that was it and then the ti for the 80
but now we've got so many freaking cards
down here if I'm confused what the hell
are you feeling I'm telling you I know
it's just one of those things where
there's no way I could do this review
and have it be 100% wanted percent
useful to everyone because if you just
up your budget by 10 bucks could make
the difference of 10 FPS depending on
the title and depending on which card
you go with but if I were a businessman
then I would say that that was clearly
the right strategic move to make in
terms of pricing because if you start
having all these options and the price
points then I guess in terms of accuracy
by volume more people are gonna buy your
stuff I'm gonna have my ear to the
ground and definitely see what the
pricing is because like I already said
the XFX thick boy was leaked on Amazon
early at two hundred and thirty dollars
mix which means you could buy a 16 60
super like I said for $10 less than that
and get a better experience than
anything you would get from the 5500
which is kind of sad because we need AMD
to do what they did with the 5700 which
is lean on NVIDIA enough to have them
change of strategy a little bit like
they did with bringing the 2070 back
because remember the 5700 XT was bumping
up against the 2070 super at a much less
price this is kind of the opposite so
sound off in the comments below I'm sure
by now you guys have seen several
reviews on this card I have not spoken
to any of my colleagues I have no idea
what anyone else's opinions are of these
cards I like to kind of quarantine
myself not because I'm gassy but because
I like to kind of be uninfluenced by
other people's testing and kind of come
up with my own
and then sort of compare notes after the
fact so you guys sound off in the
comments below how you feel AMD did with
this particular launch did they nail it
with the pricing did they win you over
are you gonna jump over to something
from the 1600 series simply because of
performance $2 that's it thanks for
watching guys and as Holy's we'll see
you in the next one